today on the matt welsh show democrats
are coming up with a million reasons to
oppose amy coney barrett because they
don't want to be honest about the real
reason which is that
she might make it harder to kill babies
that's what they're really upset about
also five headlines including absurd
claims of voter suppression which we
will analyze
and a harrowing video of an encounter
between a mountain lion and a hiker that
you don't want to miss
in our daily cancellation i'll be
canceling everybody involved in a viral
video
of a woman forcing her boyfriend to
marry her at a target all of that coming
up but first
you know there are a lot of companies
out there working constantly to
undermine
our values as conservatives sometimes
you think you know it might be nice to
have a few companies who are actually on
our side well the good news is i'll give
you one company
i can tell you about the pro-life phone
company charity mobile
with charity mobile five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice there
are all kinds of other perks too
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
and
you get all that despite there being no
contracts no termination fees
no risk with a 30-day guarantee i can
tell you i've been using charity mobile
for a few months now and i love having
the knowledge that i'm getting a great
price and great service
but also supporting the pro-life cause
at the same time a cause that's
especially relevant now
uh during the supreme court hearings and
we're hearing a lot about it so
uh now's a great time to call charity
mobile at one eight seven 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
okay now speaking of the hearings one
must feel a certain amount of
sympathy for the democrats who have been
put in the unenviable position of having
to invent some reason to oppose the
confirmation of a universally respected
admired
well-qualified female supreme court
justice
presumably they've already skimmed
through her high school yearbook
found no ammunition there probably
decided to be too
difficult uh you know to make outlandish
sexual assault
allegations stick to a woman especially
and particularly when they didn't even
stick to brett kavanaugh
so their options here are very limited
and as the senate confirmation hearings
unfold this week
democrats and their allies in the media
have tried a number of different tax
you know they've they've looked at a few
different ways they can go about this
and with with no success at all having
realized that their
ginsburg's dying wish gambit also wasn't
landing because there is no dying wish
clause in the constitution as it turns
out
they've rallied around the almost as
absurd notion that republicans would be
guilty of court packing should they
exercise their constitutional power to
confirm a supreme court nominee like we
talked about yesterday senator dick
durbin
lamented that republicans have quote
taken every vacancy and filled it
pretending not to know
that court packing is not when vacancies
are filled but when they are
created by adding seats
what else are republicans supposed to do
with a vacancy but fill it
saving a few for the democrats might be
good sportsmanship but that hardly
qualifies as a constitutional
obligation nor as a persuasive argument
during opening statements on monday
senator cory booker
claimed that the hearing was
illegitimate because
as he eloquently put it listen the
american people should decide
the american people should decide the
american
people should decide
i will not be voting to confirm judge
barrett's nomination
very dramatic stuff there from corey
very affecting i felt that
senator amy klobuchar for her part
tweeting during the hearing when she
really should have been paying attention
i think
posted this isn't donald trump's country
it's yours
this shouldn't be donald trump's judge
it should be yours
but what these appeals to democracy
ignore is that the electorate
gave control of the senate to
republicans and elected donald trump to
a four-year term
their mandate from the voters like their
constitutional power doesn't expire a
month before the next election
the american people did decide or to put
it in terms
cory booker might be able to understand
the american people did decide the
american people did decide the american
people
did decide democrats in the hearing
have repeatedly tried to make hay out of
the fact that we're in the middle of a
pandemic
so we've heard a lot about that on
monday senator maisie hirono spent her
opening statement recounting the horrors
of the coronavirus
and its effects on the economy or rather
the effects of the lockdown on the
economy
but she could never quite explain why
the coronavirus should prevent a supreme
court justice from being confirmed
especially when it didn't prevent
hundreds of black lives matter rallies
all across the country for three months
in a row
booker sputtered something about how
it's not
normal this isn't normal to have
confirmation hearings
during a pandemic it isn't normal now
the obvious
response to that claim is so what
pandemics themselves aren't normal
therefore the things we do
during them won't be normal but that
doesn't mean we should stop doing things
as much as that has actually been the
strategy of course for the last six
months
not a good one and speaking of normal it
wasn't normal to attempt to block a
supreme court nominee by accusing him of
being a serial gang rapist
democrats seem to aspire to normalcy
only under very limited circumstances
and of course some of the criticisms of
barrett have taken a more personal tone
much has been made of the fact that she
served as a handmaid in a group called
people of praise
but the protesters dressed in ridiculous
red costumes outside the hearing seem
not to know that
handmade in barrett's case was reference
to the bible
not a book written by margaret atwood in
the 1980s
and this sort of confusion is inevitable
when your exposure to historical
literature extends only to that novel
plus harry potter and twilight
now predictably the fact that barrett
has seven children has also been the
subject of attack
many examples here here's just one
author lauren hoff
mocked the judge for her quote clown car
vagina
many of the twitter followers laughed
and applauded one of them commented that
um
delivering a child is like quote taking
a dump
now i'm tempted to say that many of
barrett's critics are jealous that she's
an attractive and successful woman
with a husband and children well they
have only their cats and netflix
accounts to keep them company
as they slowly shrivel away into
nothingness to be forgotten by everyone
and mourned by no one
but i'm not going to say that because it
would be uncharitable i won't say that
someone might say that but i'm not going
to anyway the interesting thing is that
this narrative of amy coney barrett the
barefoot baby factory
handmade submissive is being advanced
alongside the claim
that as slate argued this week she is a
ruthless self-promoting careerist
who's concerned only with her own
professional advancement
now of course god forbid anyone were to
utter such slander about say
senator camilla harris who began her
political career in bed with a
well-connected and still married we
might add
california politician it'd be
horrifically sexist to make that sort of
charge against
the democratic vice presidential
candidate but bear it for obvious
reasons
for obvious political reasons is fair
game
these are all the desperate cries of
people
who cannot utter their real objection
except in euphemism
harris joining the hearing remotely
declared that barrett would
undo ginsburg's legacy by the way there
is no clause in the
constitution requiring that a deceased
justice's legacy be respected
or upheld either um and she also said
that barrett would roll back americans
rights
what she means here what everyone's
cited above really means is that
justice amy coney barrett might make it
harder for parents to legally kill their
children
this is the real source of all of the
impotent rage being directed at the
nomination the hearings and barrett
personally
if she believed in a mother's right to
kill her offspring none of the people
mentioned here
would be objecting on the contrary they
would extol her brilliance and beauty
and bravery
and their venom would be reserved for
the people doing what they themselves
are doing right now
democrats have no problem with this
flagrant hypocrisy because
they believe themselves to be opposing
literally hitler
the other side of the aisle to them
represents
abject evil racism bigotry the
enslavement of women
those in their camp who don't believe
this at least want everyone to believe
they believe it
but meanwhile it doesn't require
exaggeration or hysteria or recourse to
dystopian fantasy novels to believe
rather to notice to know
that they are the ones who actually do
support fund and facilitate one of the
most hideous forms of evil the world has
ever seen
60 million human beings have been
butchered since and because of
the supreme court decision that these
people hail as the high water mark of
the civil rights movement
many of these humans have been killed in
the very early stages of pregnancy a
fact that makes their murder no less
evil
but many millions have been executed at
a stage late enough
to require dismemberment before the
corpses can be extracted from the womb
this mass grave this mountain of corpses
this
systematic extermination of our own
children is what cory booker camilla
harris joe biden
all the rest of them are so jealously
and vengefully guarding
they pretend to be fighting evil and
they've given themselves the moral
license to lie and cheat to that end
but they are in fact the genocidal
fascists
they pretend to oppose and we should
always keep that in mind when we watch
the hearings
this week let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know small businesses have been
getting completely decimated uh ever
since the lockdown started
i hear the stories all the time we all
hear the stories and maybe
if you're listening you are
unfortunately one of these stories
uh so the the fact is a lot of people
millions and millions are feeling the
effects of the lockdown and that's why
we're excited to tell you that next week
the daily wire god king jeremy boring is
going to be presenting alongside a team
of world-renowned business leaders
at expert ownership live there's no
better time for something like this
it's a two-day virtual conference about
leading through crisis
the conference features a lineup of
speakers like leadership author john
maxwell
plus the founders of duck commander and
otterbox plus the benham brothers
many others who can relate to what
entrepreneurs and leaders are going
through right now
uh because they they're going through it
themselves they'll share stories about
their own businesses startup journeys as
well
uh the tough times that their companies
went through and how they were able to
navigate
those challenges and come out on the
other side of it so go to expert
ownership live dot com slash walsh
before midnight to register
and get a second ticket for a friend 50
off
but the urgent point is that if you
register today
today is the last day to register for
147
before prices go up so it's 147 dollars
if you register right now it's the last
day
then you also get that second ticket for
a friend for 50 off at
expertownershiplive.com
invest in yourself and in your business
simultaneously and
come on you don't want to miss the god
king so you got to go expert ownership
live.com walsh it's 147 for today
only before prices go up again expert
ownership
live.com walsh to secure your spot today
all right i want to show you one other
thing from the hearings uh this this
this i have to mention
because it just exemplifies
the fact that the whole mask thing is
largely for show so let me
i'll show you this one example okay
chosen at random you'll see this senator
getting ready to speak
and then and then watch what he does
watch well definitely some good news uh
senator lee's enthusiasm for the dormant
commerce clause convinces me you've made
a full recovery
senator white house mr chairman
judge barrett america is worried
about one thing above all else right now
and it's our health okay so you see as
soon as he
as he's about to start speaking he rips
the mask off
with a vengeance he rips it off eagerly
and like slams it down the table
and i understand that you know when that
whenever i go grocery shopping
at a store where i'm required to wear it
as soon as i get outside
as soon as i exit the door i'm ripping
that that thing off
and like falling to my knees and gasping
for breath as if i've just come up
for air after a free dive to the bottom
of the ocean and i'm always perplexed to
see that that's what i do right but i'm
perplexed
to look around and see that it seems
like everyone else
they leave the store and keep the mask
on as they walk across the parking lot
to their cars and they keep the mask on
when they get into their car too
like they like having it on i can't wait
to take it off
um so that you know i get that and i
also understand wanting to
take the mask off so that you can speak
and be understood that's one of the many
frustrating aspects of this mask thing
is that you can't understand what the
hell people are saying
in fact i was at a store last night and
i was i was trying to talk to the guy
behind the camera
behind the the counter rather but he had
a mask on
and there was glass up the gl it wasn't
like bulletproof glass for
no glass put there for the coronavirus
uh the magical glass that we see
everywhere so he had a glass the glass
up
mask on and he also had a pretty thick
accent so
i'm trying to communicate with him i
can't understand what the hell he's
saying i we we
we can't understand each other and so it
was just uh
it was just one of those things where i
had to say oh okay yeah all right
i hope i'm giving the the correct
general response because i don't know
what you're saying to me
that's how it is you can't understand
what anyone's saying you can't see
anybody's face
i think there's a psychological effect
there too
there's a lot of i think psychologists
in the future are going to have a lot of
fun going back and looking at how we're
all affected by this but going months
and months in public
it's case depends on where you live
because some areas
mercifully are not as strict about it
but
at least where i live everybody has it
on all the time and so you go months at
a time
out in public and you never see
anybody's face and you can't really
understand them either
anyway so um
that part i understand but but but
here's here's my my point
if you're gonna take it off to speak why
are you wearing it
at all the senators are sitting there
wearing the mask
and they're not talking they're just
breathing normally
and then they take it off at precisely
the moment when they would be the most
likely to spread it
though it's still extremely unlikely but
but still it's incoherent if you're
gonna wear the mask
wear the damn mask but if you're gonna
do
what i would say is the reasonable thing
and not wear it when you're trying to
speak
then what's the medical reason to wear
it at all it's like when you go to a
restaurant now
and they say you know wear the mask when
you come in and you're walking to your
table you got to wear the mask for that
and then and then you sit down and you
take it off and you carry on a loud
conversation spewing your fumes
this way and that again i'm not saying
that you should wear your mask when you
sit down
to actually eat your dinner i see some
people doing that and it's completely
insane but
what i'm saying is what the hell is the
actual point of wearing it on your way
to the table
when you're not saying anything and then
you sit down and then you take it off
of course it's an offshoot of the
airline thing where you have to remain
socially distanced and they're very
strict about it
remain socially distanced uh in line
to get on the plane and then be packed
in like sardines
breathing recycle there for the next six
hours it just it it doesn't make any
sense
it's all for show okay number two
we're always hearing about this mythical
beast called voter suppression
we hear about it um we're warned about
it
but we never actually see it
we never see this voter suppression in
action until now
claire mccaskill uploaded a video from
georgia and that i think she took
herself i'm not sure about that but
she uploaded this video got a lot of
attention uh went viral
polls opened you know for for in person
voting in georgia at least in this in
this part of georgia
and um she took a video and she says
that this proves voter suppression it's
a video of voter suppression
so what are we going to see here we're
going to see voters being blocked from
the entrance are we going to see voters
being thrown out of polling stations by
by bouncers what are we going to see
well
here's the video this is it right here
this
this
is the voter suppression as you can see
a whole bunch of people lined up to vote
three weeks before the election
this is voter suppression they say
hundreds of people
being able to vote three weeks early
is suppression right
actually no no that's not what
suppression is the fact that this line
exists
is not evidence that people aren't able
to vote in fact it's evidence of the
opposite
in the same way that a long line for a
star wars film
is not evidence that people aren't able
to watch star wars
a long line for a roller coaster is not
evidence
that the amusement park doesn't want you
on the roller coaster
it's evidence that they want you on it
and a lot of people want to do it and so
and you can only you know get bored so
many people at a time
you'd only get so many people into the
building at a time especially now with
all these cobid restrictions
so we're going to pretend that that's
got no factor at all either
it's just it's it's com it's
what they are putting forth as evidence
of voter suppression
is evidence of the opposite of it it's
evidence against voter suppression
we are three weeks before the election
and there's a line around the freaking
block of people who can vote
yes it might take a little bit it's
inconvenient someone i was talking about
this and someone said to me
well it's this is about the
inconveniences so what
doesn't mean you can't do it just
because your inconvenience doesn't mean
you're being
suppressed or oppressed if it's that
important to you then you'll just wait
in line no big deal
if it's not that important to you then
don't do it no skin off my back i've
made my point
clear there as well i don't think we
need to
go out of our way to make sure that
every last person votes
um but if you want to you can
okay number three news in the harvard
gazette
says uh people who survive serious cova
19 infections have long lasting immune
responses against the virus according to
a new study led by researchers at
harvard-affiliated
massachusetts general hospital the
researchers found that levels of an
antibody called
immunoglobulin g remained elevated in
infected patients for four months and
were associated with the presence of
protective neutralizing antibodies which
also demonstrated little decrease in
activity over time
uh so yeah that's that's that's kind of
what i thought and i if i've said it
once i've said it a thousand times
um it's all about the immunoglobulin g
you guys have heard me go on about
immunoglobulin g
many times i you know i'm always talking
about it and um
so this is good news anyway but of
course when trump made this claim about
himself
that maybe he's immune now it was called
fake news
in fact i believe twitter flagged it as
fake news
censored the uh the tweet
i wonder if they'll do the same with
harvard probably not okay kanye west
has released his first campaign ad
the moment we've all been waiting for
here it is america
what is america's destiny what is best
for our nation
our people what is just true justice
we have to think about all these things
together as a people
to contemplate our future to live up to
our dream
we must have vision we as a people will
revive
our nation's commitment to faith to what
our constitution calls the free exercise
of religion
including of course prayer through
prayer
faith can be restored we as a people
are called to a greater purpose than
ourselves we are not
only a beacon to the world but we should
be servants to each other
to encourage each other to help each
other to lift up each other
our fellow americans that we may all
prosper together
we have to act on faith with the sure
knowledge
that we are pursuing the right goals and
doing the right things
we will build a stronger country by
building stronger families
families are the building blocks of
society
of a nation by turning to faith we will
be the kind of nation
the kind of people god intends us to be
i am kanye west and i approve this
message
okay so i have to say the production
quality and presentation here is is not
the best
um and i'd expect maybe a little bit
more from an artistic visionary
but the message is on point is and you
know i i think the message is great i'm
on board with with most of what he has
to say
his campaign website um has this ad
and then right under the ad is a bunch
of merchandise you could buy
and then right under that is the
presidential platform
a lot of it is kind of the typical
political talking points that you would
get from a sort of democrat-like
kind of person but um the first item on
the platform is good it says
restore faith and revive our
constitutional commitment to freedom of
religion and the free exercise of one's
faith demonstrated by restoring prayer
in the classroom including spiritual
foundations
i like it i think that and i think this
should be the message
of the republican party as well which it
is sometimes
when they feel like focusing on it so i
don't know i might have to vote for
kanye
he's a bit eccentric but then again if
you're trying to avoid eccentricities in
this election
probably your best just not voting at
all number five a little nightmare fuel
for you a jogger in provo utah was out
on a trail recently um
when apparently he unknowingly got close
to
some mountain lion clubs uh cubs that is
rather
so mountain lion was it getting next to
a mountain lion club where they're all
gathered together probably not a good
idea
either but especially a mountain lion
cub is what he apparently
came in the vicinity of i don't think he
knew that but then
mama mountain lion uh appeared on the
scene
and was not too happy about it and
here's how that went
holy [ __ ] no go away
go away no
no [ __ ] you dude
holy
gosh where's my gun
okay this is when i
die nope
get the [ __ ] away stupid kitty cat
holy come on dude i don't feel like
dying today
that lasted for six minutes we can't
play the whole thing of course six
minutes
he was backing up as the mountain lion
escorted him
away from the premises now the cat was
not some of the
headlines i've seen about this have said
that the cat was stalking him
but no she wasn't stalking wasn't trying
to eat him if she wanted to eat them
she would have i think if a mountain
lion is stalking you when you're
jogging then you're screwed that's it
you're not gonna you're not gonna see it
coming until
the thing's jaws are around your neck
but um
uh still i mean he's backing away if he
if he had made any
wrong move here taking a wrong step
literally he would have been dead
like what i was worried about the whole
time watching this video is if this guy
trips while walking backwards on this
path
with a bunch of rocks and roots and
stuff if he trips he's done
um if he had turned and run away he'd be
done
so not a lot of room for error and it
seems he mostly did the right thing he
backed away slowly
he kept eye contact with the cat he
screamed he tried to make himself bigger
he threw something
crack crouching down to pick up the rock
is a very risky
proposition when you're face to face
with a mountain lion but
for the most part i think a pretty good
strategy there
and obviously he survived so proof is in
the pudding
that said far be it for me to monday
morning quarterback something like this
but i will say
if you're ever in this situation one
quick note i would make
put the phone down there is no advantage
to filming it
this isn't like you're in a
confrontation with the police and you
want to film it so that you can sue them
later
there's not any suing the mountain lion
if uh if she rips your face off that's
not gonna happen so
there's there's no conceivably good
reason to film in a situation like this
and it does hamper you because you're
looking down at the camera
plus you're not able to you know you
want to be waving your arms and making
yourself as big as possible so he's
holding his camera like this he might be
waving with the other hand
but he's you know that second arm could
make a big difference
um so i i you know this
i i i would just say if if you're if
you're facing the possibility
of being eaten um
probably your priority in that situation
shouldn't be let me get this because
it's going to make a great viral video
it does make a great video this is a
really compelling video i have to say
but that you know that probably
shouldn't be your priority um
finally bonus story here number six from
religion news religion news reporter
alejandra
molina says amy coney barrett nomination
fight leaves progressive
catholics feeling unseen i spoke with
black and latinx catholics
who believe in abortion rights and
marriage equality to learn how the focus
on white conservative catholicism
overshadows their faith
yes catholics who believe in abortion
rights
and gay marriage i can think of many
similar reports you could file
like i spoke with carnivorous vegans to
learn how the focus on vegetarian vegans
overshadows them or i spoke with
god-fearing atheists to learn how the
focus on godless atheists
overshadows them you know things like
that there are many
many examples there is of course no such
thing uh is the point i'm trying to make
here there is no such thing as a
catholic who believes in abortion rights
because that would be a catholic
who rejects the moral authorities this
is not a it's not a small detail okay
if you're a catholic claim that you
support abortion rights then you are
catholic who
me this means that you reject the moral
authority of the church
and if you reject the moral authority of
the church then you're not a catholic
you don't have to be a catholic you're
not you're not required to be
but being a catholic is a certain thing
this means you're not just like anything
else
you can't say i'm a mormon but i reject
most of the teachings of the mormon
church well then you're not a mormon
you can be something else if you want to
be but you can't be that because that's
what it means to be that
uh but we're going to see a lot more of
this kind of thing as the week goes on
i'm sure okay let's get to our daily
cancellation but before we do that don't
want to forget it is baseball season and
the
old glory daily wire baseball bat is
back this is a limited edition
hand-crafted custom painted baseball bat
emblazoned with the daily wire logo
very nice looking thing when we um first
put this bat out it was a numbered
edition a few months ago and it sold out
in 48 hours and that was when it was
only available to
all access members so it was a limit
it's a limited edition for a limited
number of people
now anyone can purchase it but inventory
is still limited so you got to go and
get yours now before they're gone text
the keyword
baseball to eight three four zero zero
baseball to eight three four zero zero
and purchase your bat today okay
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation a video
that may or may not be totally staged
and fake honestly i didn't do much
research into it before i started
shooting the show today
mostly because i'm lazy and also because
i really need this video for show
content so
i'm gonna assume it's real you see i
like
literally everyone else in media i am at
this point barely human
i think of everything in terms of
whether i can use it for content that's
the only thing i care about
actually i can relate to the jogger
filming his own potential mauling
because i might do the same
to be honest with you like if i were to
accidentally drive off of a 500 foot
cliff
the last thing i would think as i plunge
to my death is that at least
if i somehow survive this it will make
great content
but anyway my sociopathy isn't really
the point today the point is that this
video
which appears to show a woman fed up
with her boyfriend
you know and fed up with him not sealing
the deal deciding to put on a wedding
dress and a fanny pack for some reason
grab her enabling bridesmaid and somehow
a minister
and go to her boyfriend's job which is
at target to force him to marry her
this is really a form of kidnapping it
seems to me but uh
here is the the footage watch
to do it or this out now we're getting
married right now
or i'm leaving i'm out i'm done
like if you don't marry me this second i
brought the pastor
chase my bridesmaid hi guys i'm just
finally making him commit
you know like we're getting married now
or like it's over
do it yeah we can't talk about this
outside
shaping
now perhaps unsurprisingly uh i am
canceling all parties concerned here i
cancel the would-be bride on the general
grounds of her
apparently being a lunatic though i
suppose she gets points for getting
married in a target parking lot rather
than doing the whole elaborate
traditional wedding routine because if
she did the traditional wedding routine
one shudders to imagine what sort of
bridezilla she would be
she strikes me as the type of bride who
would break down in tears in the middle
of reception because
the napkins are the wrong shade of white
or something
in fact now that i think of it we may be
asking the wrong question about this
incident we're asking whether it's
staged but do we even know
if that guy was actually her boyfriend
how do we know they knew each other at
all maybe she met him for the first time
the previous tuesday
when she went to target and he was
working and she stopped him to ask
ask if they sell sweaters for poodles
and his friendliness gave her the
impression that they were madly in love
so she showed up a few days later with a
priest and demanded that they marry on
the spot
you know it's a tale as old as time
classic love story could be the case
here
we really don't know but she's she's
she's canceling cancelled i also cancel
the man though because
couple of reasons first of all you have
done something wrong in your
relationship
if you have given your girlfriend the
impression that it would be acceptable
for her to come to your work
in a wedding dress and ask to get
married real quick on your lunch break
also i'm cancelling him on the
assumption let's just assume
that it's true that he's been engaged to
her for two years
and is stringing her along her approach
here is ill-advised on a number of
levels but
she's right at least that two years is
too long so she's correct on that score
i'll defend her there
so he is canceled for that and they are
canceled together they have that in
common at least
perhaps it can serve as the foundation
for their new life together as a married
couple
their mutual cancellation i don't know
now i understand
that people today people in my
generation
uh are afraid of marriage allergic to it
that's why marriage rates have been
dropping while unmarried cohabitation
skyrockets and i understand to some
extent
uh why this fear of marriage is there
it's it's
somewhat justified older generations the
boomer generation
they complain about millennials being
afraid of commitment but
where do you think we contracted this
particular disease from
baby boomers got divorced like it was
their hobby like it was their favorite
thing in the world to do
my parents are still married but growing
up half of my friends had divorced
parents by the time i was in middle
school so
a lot of people in my generation grew up
in broken homes
and didn't get the greatest example of
marriage if you're wondering why your
kids
don't want to get married consider the
possibility that they were turned off
from the whole enterprise because you
suck so bad at it maybe
that said you could only use mommy and
daddy as an excuse for so long and
swearing off marriage doesn't really
make sense
unless you're gonna swear off romantic
relationships completely and live a
celibate life in which case
more power to you there's something to
be said for that perhaps but
if you still want to have that sort of
companionship
then you really have two ways of going
about it number one
strive to find and form a lasting
committed stable relationship with
someone you
who you can come to know and love and
with whom you can build a family and a
life together and grow old
by each other's side or two you can
wander from one meaningless
self-centered temporary relationship to
another
the thrill of something new quickly
giving way to dissolution and heartbreak
again and again and again until
finally you're too old for that sort of
thing your physical beauty wears away
and
ultimately you're left alone with no one
by your side an old age and
no child to care for you those are
really your two options
that's really it of course option one
can turn into option two if the marriage
doesn't work out but still
at the end of the day these are broadly
speaking what you have to choose from
if you don't want to be celibate and
become a hermit which again
more power to you if that's what you
want to do to each their own but i would
highly recommend
option one and if you're gonna go with
option one that requires some
decisiveness and yes a little bit of
risk you're never gonna know
everything there is to know about
someone before you get married there's
always gonna be some mystery
in the other which is a good thing if
you look at it the right way
and that means there's always going to
be a little bit of a leap you have to
take when you tie the knot
yet yet putting off the leap won't
accomplish much
there's only so much you can feasibly
learn about somebody
before you've married them it's part of
the bargain
and as far as that goes you'll have
learned almost all that you can learn
very quickly one thing i hear from
people a lot is that well
you know we have to live together for
five years before marriage
to find out if the other person has
annoying habits are you kidding
of course they have annoying habits
everyone does i have approximately 900
000 annoying habits my wife has counted
all of them
but you learn to have fun with the
annoying habits at least i do
my wife doesn't like the sound of
chewing so what do i do well
when we're watching a movie i i
intentionally
chomp on a bowl of tortilla chips just
to piss her off it's a great time
intentionally annoying her is my love
language because i'm essentially still
in sixth grade emotionally speaking
so don't worry about that sort of thing
you you it'll happen your work around it
um i tend to think you can know if
somebody is marriage material
and whether you want to marry them in
like a month
i know i did with my wife but let's be
cautious and say
six months by six months you will know
almost everything you can know about
that person before marriage
it's possible they're hiding some deep
dark secret it's possible your beloved
is a chainsaw murderer
but frankly if you haven't figured that
out in six months of dating you probably
won't figure it out in six years either
and besides chainsaw murdering isn't a
deal breaker in a marriage
you can work around that too spice of
life and all that
so make your decision in six months get
engaged
get married six months after that one
year is all you should need
one year that's it one and done let's
say that's what i did
and so i decided that of course everyone
else should do it too
and when i am theocratic fascist
dictator of america this will be
obviously required by law under my
regime upon reaching upon reaching
adulthood you will be given six months
to find someone and get married if you
don't find anyone
somebody will be assigned to you the
wedding will be carried out shortly
after that
there will be no reception as music and
dancing will be of course banned
and then you'll have 24 hours for a
honeymoon at six flags or something
before being sent to
work in the factories for the rest of
your life there may be a few flaws in
that sort of system i admit but
it's better than what we're doing now uh
in fact really anything is better than
what we're doing now
uh actually what you just saw there is
is is is
probably better than the way that most
people my generation handle
relationships so maybe i don't cancel
them
in fact maybe i cancel everybody else
you know it's and and look they have a
great story to tell they're kids one day
if everything works out um
and i you know i i think that uh should
it go that way
when the kids finally hear that story
they won't be surprised because they'll
know their mom and
and they'll hear that story and think
yeah well that sounds like mom
all right so uh who am i canceling uh
i'm canceling uh commitment averse
millennials i guess that's that that in
the end is canceled i guess the guy the
guy is canceled
not the woman we we went on a
circuitous path here but this is where
we ended up okay
that'll do it for us today uh thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there